not for the first time tonight David
cameras in order to talk about the past
he doesn't want to talk about the future
David you just said that you were
tackling tax avoidance let's look at the
reality on this you haven't acted on the
tax havens you haven't acted on the
hedge funds we've shown how you can
raise over a billion pounds as far about
two and a half billion pounds time to
care fund for the NHS it'll have 20,000
more nurses 8,000 more doctors 5,000
more care workers and 3,000 more
midwives now you have to ask yourself at
home
why won't David Cameron act on those
hedge funds they fund his party he won't
act by leadership that will stand up and
act to tackle taxes once again he's
wrong just this week we've introduced a
diverted profits tax to go after these
companies that make money in Britain and
don't pay tax in Britain but here's what
ed Miliband isn't telling you because he
doesn't support any of the spending
reductions and efficiencies we've had to
make he wants to make a very big cut he
wants to put up taxes and cut your pay
going into your monthly pay slip at the
end of the month and taking your money
out because he thinks he can spend that
money better than you that would be a
great mistake for our coz only doesn't
up I you know it's just madness Agra
dismiss tomorrow back Thank You Nick
astonish